so i guess sometimes you just have to go
for it
when the feeling takes you you just got
to make your move right
hey guys pete here this will be my for
all mankind
season 2 episode 7 breakdown quick
spoiler warning if you haven't seen it
yet this video will definitely spoil it
for you
just hit the subscribe button go watch
it get caught up and then come back when
you're finished
because it is the kind of episode you're
going to want to talk about with that
out of the way let's get to it
so there's a lot going on in this
episode and i did mention in my last
video that there was something up that i
thought they were foreshadowing
something with thomas payne
and we do start off with him and ellen
having drinks getting ready to fly to
seoul
they're going there in their role to
represent nasa and the us government
before they can go they have a
conversation how she was born to do this
job
we see that she's thinking of stepping
down and she almost gets a chance to
before she gets a phone call her
father's had a heart attack and without
thinking twice
payne encourages her to go there tells
her to cancel the trip
and says this is family he continues on
without her and we soon learned that
payne is a passenger
on kal-007 we see him talk to margot
about work
they're talking about a proposed space
station we watch as the soviet fighter
jet is following the commercial airliner
and then we see his last moments before
an air-to-air missile
explodes nearby kal-7
is something that really happened in our
timeline it's wild to think that a
passenger flight like this was shot down
and over 200 passengers mostly civilians
were killed
this isn't even the only flight like
this in the 1980s though
just five years later the u.s shot down
iran
air flight 655 and all 290 people on
board were killed
i'm not old enough to remember kal-007
but i did go and look at the wikipedia
article look at some of the news reports
from that time
and also things that have come out in
the last few decades as more information
has been made available
to me it looks like the incident mostly
plays out the same way in both timelines
the passenger flight is shot down after
crossing into restricted airspace
this was a huge deal in our timeline
there was international
outrage it gave birth to a lot of
conspiracy theories about what really
happened
and it certainly ratcheted up the
intensity of the cold war
in the show's timeline the ripple effect
means there are
immediate consequences related to our
story as the space race is ongoing
with the tensions building on the moon
and in panama at the same time
of course we lose thomas payne who both
margot
and ellen have become closer to over
this season
and because the apollo soyuz is
happening at this time instead of when
it originally did in our timeline
that means that there are soviet
engineers in the us
and we have the apollo crew visiting
star city
one thing that's weird about the show's
timeline is that weird introduction
scene where danny first arrived in the
soviet union
a lot of people pointed out after the
episode that you wouldn't expect the
soviet union to act that way
it would make a lot more sense for them
to be competing with the us
and had a situation where they tried to
out do the welcome that was given for
their
people who were visiting everything else
happens in chronological order so i'm
not sure why that one feels so out of
place
but it is possible that the intention
was that kal-007 already happened when
dany arrives
either way we find out that ellen's dad
is okay he's laid up after his heart
attack
they have a conversation where she tells
him she's thinking of leaving nasa but
then again she gets another call this
time from the white house
telling her to look at the tv and we all
get filled in on the reactions to the
kal
news some of what we see here is
actually taken from the news
in our timeline later at jsc we see the
characters at nasa trying to figure out
what happened
and through bradford we find out that
they're paranoid because there are spy
planes flying over
all the time we also learned that ellen
will be
acting as payne's replacement as the
director of nasa
so danny is in star city she's locked in
her room
both sides are cutting off all
communication so margot has the idea
that she's going to go to see
sergey to see if he can't get through so
they can at least talk to the astronauts
and make sure they're all right
she has an impressive back and forth
with the soldier who's watching sergey's
office
and after a memorable exchange he makes
it inside to talk to him
they talk about payne being a good man
and we see that this is a tough
situation all the way around
in the end they agree to help each other
and we can see that they still have that
connection that was building up over the
last couple episodes
at home we see ellen on the phones she's
doing her job
we see pam show up there's a moment when
she stops and she sees how good ellen is
at her job it's obvious that she feels
like this is a problem for their
relationship
but at the same time she's not sure if
she should ask her to give that
up later when they're in her room and
ellen's still on the phone
it looks obvious that pam is thinking
about what's going on with things
she's supportive and it's clear she
wants to be with her but then we see as
she's comforting her
the president himself calls on the phone
he gives condolences for tom
tells her he's going to need her going
forward and says that they have to show
strength in the shadow of catastrophe or
all
is lost so we see that ellen is being
pulled in different directions
bradford comes to see margot in her
office he has spy
images that show that the soviets have
moved their bronze shuttle
onto the launch pad margot didn't
realize that they were this close to
launch
and this is all in the alternate
timeline territory here
the photos are from socklin island and
we see that this makes her wonder about
kal-7 he confirms that they were taken
by an sr-71 blackbird though not the
commercial airliner
although she says you're telling me that
kla was flying over the same island
baran is launching from
and these two things aren't connected
and to that he just says that's not why
i'm here
the real reason he's there is because he
wants to know if the shuttle can be
armed when she looks at the plans she
realizes they're exactly the same
so of course it could be armed just like
the us's version could be
she realizes that they have the same
design from two years ago which means
they don't know about the o-ring problem
that brought the challenger down in our
timeline in the show's timeline they
caught that flaw
they corrected it and therefore the
disaster never happened
and when she realizes that they have the
same problem she wants to inform them
but bradford is totally against it i
thought this was a pretty good play
in that telling them that they know that
they have the same problem
would compromise people that they're
using for their intelligence gathering
so he's kind of worried about losing
that intelligence advantage
while she's worried about the people who
could die as a result
and you can see where both of them are
coming from in having opposing views
here
and the fact that they could arm the
shuttle hints at escalation
and we see a little bit of the fear of
the dod coming in
when larry and ellen are having a
conversation in their kitchen
she's overwhelmed with the job she's
distracted because she wants to walk
away she wants to live her life with pam
but she's also very dedicated to the
space program and the idea of getting to
mars
larry gives her the idea that if she
doesn't want the dod to take over
then she's gonna have to prove that she
has things under control
later she calls a meeting saying that
they're taking back the mining site
the president has approved it and he's
approved arming pathfinder
but all of this was under her
recommendation
these weren't the president's ideas this
was her attempt to try to keep the dod
out of nasa by taking an aggressive
approach on their own
one of my favorite parts of the episode
was when danielle gets a visit
in her room at star city the man who
comes to meet with her
never actually says what his name is he
just introduces himself as an engineer
based on what he says though it's pretty
obvious that this is supposed to be
sergey korolev
he's the man that was the force behind
the soviet space program
i think it's fair to say that he was the
driving force
behind all the advancements they made
and the showrunner ron moore has said
that his surviving in the for all
mankind
timeline is where the timelines diverge
in our timeline he died and their space
program
never really recovered i don't think
there's any doubt that this is supposed
to be him
he talks about the gulag which is
something that happened in real life he
spent time there
he doesn't give his name in real life
that was a security measure because they
were afraid that he would be
assassinated
so he kept his name even from the people
he worked with inside the space program
and you can hear the sense of wonder and
dedication that he has to going to space
and i think that's why i like this
exchange so much
because we have danielle she's in a
hostile situation she doesn't know
what's going on but even in that
situation these two
are able to connect through that same
passion
for exploring space he has a drink with
her he leaves the knife behind so that
she can carve her name in the door
that was a nice touch and of course she
does eventually get to leave the room
at the same time sergey is being
recalled to the soviet union
and margot goes to see him and tell him
goodbye in their conversation she
covertly tells him about the defective
o-ring problem they had
which she picks up on immediately and i
mean that's good
but it kind of worries me a little bit
at the same time i guess one thing that
might work in her favor was that
bradford told her hey they might figure
it out themselves
so i just hope she doesn't get exposed
so that's about everything that goes
down as far as the main conflict
other stuff that happens in this episode
we see kelly get the paperwork from the
adoption agency
she finds out that her mother died in
childbirth she gets to see a picture of
her birth parents
and she sends a d-mail inquiring about
her
father and by the end of the episode she
gets his address
so we'll see where that goes in the next
episode
also we see tracy's husband sam come
into the outpost
in conversation with karen he offers to
buy it which she refuses at first
only to later decide to negotiate they
do a little back and forth and she
decides to sell the bar
which okay i guess i mean she made some
money good for her
i doubt it's going to be the place where
everyone continues to go if he's the
owner but who knows
we do go back there later in the episode
though and we see karen looking around
kind of saying goodbye kind of thinking
about things
now that she sold it we hear that danny
is gonna be leaving in a week
summer vacation's over and then well
they go there
a lot of people had been worrying about
this i mean they were definitely hinting
that it's gonna happen especially with
the name of the episode
and the episode description and you
gotta give it to him he makes a move
right he turns on the jukebox
the setup's complete he already told her
he remembered seeing her
dancing alone in her living room she
starts dancing he makes a move he gives
her a kiss
and after some hesitation she does kiss
him back
but then she freaks out and leaves and
she goes home to wake up bed
and she makes love to him and i don't
really know what to say about that
other than it seems like she was into it
but then she caught herself and decided
it wasn't something that she wanted to
do
this is super weird i mean she used to
babysit him
it's shane's best friend it just feels
like if they were gonna have her
have an affair this season why not do it
with anybody else
i'm not sure what the idea behind the
long-term plan they're thinking about is
here i mean
based on their history it just feels a
little uncomfortable but i guess we'll
see what they're
going for we also had a little bit
of elena and margot together margot
walks up as
she's cursing out the vending machine
and tells her to try some negative
pressure calling back to that
scene in the early episodes they go into
her office and have a drink
and they start talking about bill her
boss
marco says that he's tough to get along
with but he's very committed to his job
then she tells her this really
embarrassing story about
bill peeing his pants after being at his
console for over 23 hours
she also mentions the nickname peanut
and this all sounds like a bad idea
on the one hand she's telling her you
have to learn to get along with him
he's not the last difficult person
you're going to have to deal with in
your profession
on the other hand we know that elena has
a history of getting fired from
everywhere she works and it sounds like
it's always been related to her
not getting along with her superiors to
me this conversation
and her knowing that about bill is going
to come back up later
we don't spend a lot of time on the moon
but what happens there is all pretty
eventful
because the timeline to take the mining
site back has been moved up
the marines asked tracy to fly the lsam
for the mission
she agrees and we see this at the end of
the episode they take off
she does a great job of piloting the
marines start humming the ride of the
valkyrie
so i guess the apocalypse now exists in
this timeline
and it's a pretty intense sequence when
they come around the last turn they see
things are different than what they're
expecting so tracy does some good
piloting
is able to get them on the ground safely
and when the two cosmonauts that are
there
see that they have guns they just take
off so at least at this point
things went smoothly they're able to
take back the site they replaced the
flag
and while i don't think this will be the
end of it that is where this episode
ends so a strong episode it did jump
around a lot but all the stories seem to
be heading in the same direction
i think the one outlier is the karen and
danny thing
but everything else seems to be falling
into place
sad to see thomas payne go they did a
good job of making him a sympathetic
character throughout this season
it'll be interesting to see how margot
and ellen
both do what they can to keep his vision
alive in nasa
it was sad to see him go but it was an
intense sequence seeing the plane being
taken out
and i thought they did a pretty good job
of integrating this thing that happened
in our timeline
into the alternate timeline to see how
things play out differently
i already said i really like the coraleb
conversation with danny
and the whole thing with the knife and
her name on the door a pioneer
recognizing a pioneer
and it's exciting to see that the
soviets have a shuttle nearly ready to
go
margot tipping off sergey should mean
that they'll probably have that ready to
go before the end of the season
i was a little surprised to see ellen
pushing to arm pathfinder
and take back the mining site while it
was still daylight but i suppose you can
see where she's coming from what she's
thinking
there's a lot of potential for things to
get hot in the next couple of episodes
so i'm interested to see where things go
let me know in the comments what you
think what you thought of the episode
what you're hoping to see before the end
of the season
and of course all your theories about
where you think things are heading
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon